hi everyone I'm Amanda and the title of
this talk is fire emoji so a little bit
about me I was a co-organizer of our
lady Chicago with our Angela and Kaelyn
who are here tonight and I'm a data
scientist at early bird software and I
also play Ultimate Frisbee here are some
of my links so this talk is going to use
the Twitter and Google Maps API is to
figure out hopefully when where fires
happen in New York City and it's kind of
a good excuse to talk about the Drake
package which I know is touched on a
little bit before but hopefully this
will give a little bit more context and
depth to that so just a caveat if you
want to run this analysis it's in this
repository here it does require a little
bit of like API off setup nothing too
horrible but if you want to run it you
need to shut that up a little bit and
you're free to use any of the data
slides code whatever it's all in github
okay
so you might be wondering why fires good
question
so this all came about because of this
weird blue light I don't know if anyone
remembers this from late in December
it's very scary nobody knew what was
going on it's kind of all over Twitter
and then finally a mystery is solved by
this one account called NYC fire wire
which tweeted out that this is like some
sort of fire at a power plant in Astoria
like nothing to worry about no UFOs so
we're like oh okay good and I was kind
of perusing their timeline and realized
that they usually tweet out the
locations of fires and it's like sort of
predictable manner change a little bit
since February but they're still sort of
a pattern and kind of the nuggets of
goodness in here are the Burrow and the
street address and it's kind of
separated by a lot of stuff like like
random numbers like box addresses stuff
that I don't really know what that is
but my guess is that this is some way
for volunteer firefighters to be able to
find out where they can go to help fight
fires so kind of cool that there's a
pattern here and hopefully we'll be able
to get it out
there and do something with the data
okay so I'll give an overview of the
pipeline in words first and then code
later so first step of the pipeline is
gonna be we're gonna pull in a bunch of
tweets either in a first big batch or
any new ones as they come up
then we're gonna extract the addresses
out of those tweets send the addresses
to the Google Maps API to get the
latitudes and longitudes of those
addresses and then some downstream stuff
too okay so this is all in this one
repository so all the functions are
defined in this didn't start at our file
which will source in now okay so in code
this is what the pipeline looks like
we'll have a get tweets function which
is going to in this case get 3,000
tweets and then save them all to a file
then we'll pull the addresses out of
those fires out of those tweets then
send the addresses to Google Maps to get
the latitude longitude and then count up
the number of fires per latitude and
longitude combination and try and plot
them on a map so you might be sort of
noticing that this is like a pretty
linear kind of pipeline we're going from
tweets to addresses to lat/long and then
counting stuff up and that's kind of why
it's a good candidate for may be using
Drake in this case so you might be
wondering like what is Drake Drake is a
workflow manager for your R code so it
makes basically it makes changing your
code easier makes you have less to worry
about when you change your code so the
main idea is that Drake will only
rebuild the parts of your analysis that
you need to rebuild when things get out
of date and their tagline is so they
what get done what gets done stays done
so it's built and maintained by will
landau if you have any complaints about
the package or any feature requests he's
very responsive ok so I kind of came to
Drake because probably like a lot of you
my analysis directories often looks kind
of like this which is always seem like a
little bit happy to me doesn't scale
very well if you want to put another
file in here like between four and five
you got to reorder everything
you want to like reorganize your
sub-directories it can be kind of a pain
so your pipeline depends on your file
naming being up to date sourcing things
in the right order knowing when the
input data changes no one kind of which
functions and objects depend on which
other objects and functions and then
when something inevitably breaks how do
you know where it broke and can you be
sure that the intermediate data stores
are up-to-date or is it the safest thing
to just rerun the entire pipeline
soup-to-nuts again usually but like
that's kind of a pain so Drake is a nice
solution to this because it creates a
tidy data frame that shows how the
pieces of your pipeline fit together it
also creates a dependency graph of all
inputs and outputs in your pipeline
which is really good for reproducibility
especially when you use it in
conjunction with them version control
tons of support for parallel and
distributed computing backends and it's
all written in R so no writing make
files or anything like that ok
so when I'm talking about a dependency
graph it kind of looks like this and
Drake lets you visualize stuff like this
so circle means like some sort of
imported thing like the empty cars data
set triangle as a function so he's
written some function called random rows
and then those all feed into the
simulate function which generates small
and so you can kind of see how
everything fits together and what's
feeding into what green means up to date
this target has been just made so it's
up to date and none of the code has
changed if it were not up to date it
would be black ok so three pieces of
vocab targets are the objects like that
green dot that Drake generates commands
are the pieces of our code that produced
those targets and then plans wrap up the
relationship between targets and
commands ok so you can think of like a
plan as kind of that top level script
where you're like sourcing everything in
and then generating the final output the
difference is that a plan knows about
the dependencies in your code so it's a
little bit of a better solution
okay so when you're thinking about Drake
normally how I go about this is I store
all my functions in one file or one or
two files and then you create a plan
using this Drake plan function here so
if you're looking at this targets are on
the left over here and then commands are
on the right
so we're generating this target clean
data from the command clean my raw data
so clean my would be a function and then
raw data would be some data object and
then you just run make a plan and so
what Drake is gonna do is it's going to
take this plan object that we've created
and that's a data frame so it knows the
relationship the one-to-one relationship
between every target and the command
that's used to generate it and then when
you run make plan the first time it's
going to run the entire thing from
scratch and then every subsequent time
that you run make plan it's only going
to rebuild the targets that are out of
date and everything that's downstream of
those targets okay so what makes a
target out of date you can set trigger
so you can say like if this is true then
always rebuild this particular target or
something used to generate that target
or one of its upstream targets has
changed so that could be either code or
data has changed so if we're looking at
just like this highlighted row here
generating the target results from the
command analyzed my clean data Drake
will know that results depends on both
the object clean data and the function
analyze mine because they're part of the
command and so if either of those
changes if you change any code in
analyze my Drake will know that and
it'll know that results is out of date
it'll also know that report is out of
date because report depends on results
okay so you might be wondering like
where's all this stuff stored Drake
creates a hidden dot Drake directory
which you can see here and then you get
stuff out of the cache the dot Drake
directory by loading it so lo DD
actually loads it into your session and
you can wipe out the entire cache we
want to start from scratch with just
running the clean command
it also stores dependencies in the same
directory which is cool so it knows like
the relationship between every target
and every other target and that's where
it's storing in the same directory you
can access this kind of relationship
it's an eye graph object and that's kind
of how it generates those visualizations
okay so back to our without Drake kind
of approach here we're getting tweets
pulling out addresses geocoding and all
that kind of stuff if we were to run
that as a Drake plan it would look more
like this so we're getting a seed batch
of fires reaping fire so adding more
fires if there are new tweets and then
pulling out the addresses all that's all
that kind of stuff so once this isn't a
data frame so here's the visualization
of that and then data frame it looks
like that
so the visualization is kind of nice
because nobody can really keep all this
in their head or at least I can't and so
you can always go back and see like
what's feeding into what what functions
are used in what other functions what
objects depend on what and that kind of
thing and so since we haven't made this
plan yet all the targets although the
circles are out of date okay so now on
to the actual fire portion so the first
function that we're going to write is a
get tweets function and this is going to
be kind of built on top of the art we
get timeline function so what that does
is it by default gets you 100 rows for a
single Twitter handle and then like
gives you a ton of stuff that you know
you probably don't really need so
instead of that we're gonna wrap that up
into something that either pulls in a
first big batch of tweets or checks to
see if there any new tweets on Twitter
so that have a timestamp that's greater
than the greatest timestamp that we
already have and then writes out the
results to a file that could be a
database if you're doing this for real
but it'll be just a file here so that's
built on these two sort of intermediate
functions get seed tweets which either
reads in the file or gets the initial
batch from Twitter and then get more get
more to
checks okay are there any more tweets
and if so yeah pull them in and then
write them to the file okay so if we're
setting n seed tweets to 15 now this
looks a lot better
we got text created at which is
important screen name and so if we take
a little bit of a better look at the
text of the tweets you can see our
nuggets of glory here are the the Boro
and then somewhere later on is the the
street address so that's what we're
gonna be trying to pull out now okay so
a little bit of fun with regex is i'm
not going to bore you all with like all
the bazillion reg X's but for the the
case where there is a box address like
this where it's like burrow and then
like some numbers and then it says box
and then the actual street address and
just pull that out and then same thing
for the Burrow so now we have tweets
that we pulled in Street borough string
them together into address okay and so
the last step of like the main pipeline
is gonna be getting latitude and
longitude
luckily the GMAT package makes this
really easy with their reverse geocoding
geocode function so that just accepts a
string and then returns you a data frame
of latitude and longitude so if we
wanted to know where Sherlock Holmes
lives in London we can stick his address
in there and then get our data frame
back
Jiji map also has some mapping
capabilities so we can get a map of
London at whatever zoom we want and then
feed that into the GG map function and
figure out where Sherlock lives so he's
right there big blue dot
okay so that I'll go right into our
pipeline it into get lat/long and then
we're just going to unnecessary gonna
grab a tweet pull the address out and
now we can attach the latitude longitude
to that tweet yay okay last step is
counting up the number of fires per
latitude and longitude combo pretty
simple and then we can go back to GG map
and run our entire plan so here's our
plan again Drake wise we've got every
target and it's tied to every command
we have a trigger on this on this target
because we're gonna say only look for
new tweets if there are new tweets and
this is what our graph looks like after
we run the entire plan so all of our
targets are green which is which means
we have stored them in the Drake cache
they're there and we can load them into
memory if we want to okay so using about
3,000 or so tweets we can figure out
where fire has happened in New York
which is a lot of places okay yay we did
it I thought I would end on something
interactive so fired trivia so shout out
the answer if you think you know it or
even if you don't think you know it and
just want to shout something out okay
first question on what day of the week
are fires most common Saturday Friday
Monday okay someone say Wednesday
Wednesday is correct I don't know why
and I don't think that these differences
are meaning I mean maybe they are I
haven't looked at it but yeah somehow
Wednesday okay which borough has the
most fires
Brooklyn it's Brooklyn but you might be
thinking like Brooklyn has a lot of
people so which borough has the most
fires per capita Staten Island okay and
last question what time of day do you
fire is typically happen any time
yeah it's nighttime this is um sunrise
and this is sunset if you can't read it
yeah that's it thank you
[Applause]